[Music]
picture day was something that i
actually kind of dreaded you have your
picture taken that's the way it's gonna
be in the yearbook forever
little did i know that i was actually
taking part in this ritual that i would
research
what if you could write a formula so
advanced that you could wade through
millions of yearbook photos to track
social trends
researchers at uc berkeley are helping
historians do just that this project is
really about history we looked for a
data set that
would kind of capture changes in people
and we found that we could use high
school yearbooks because yearbooks have
existed in high schools in america from
about 1902 and throughout this entire
time the format has stayed exactly the
same you go to school and you dress up
nice and you stand in front of the
camera and you have your picture taken
so there's millions literally of
photographs that are basically
all the same
one of the things we were able to create
was
an average image or a composite of what
the average teen looked like in the 20th
century
we could just measure literally the
curvature
of the smile there's basically
one big up
curve
until the second world war and then
there are a couple of dips but it keeps
going up
and for every decade we found a bunch of
subgroups in the 1960s
we found for girls all these different
hairstyles there's the flip that goes
like this and then there's the beehive
which is this big
bubble thing and then in the 70s we get
the afros and the buffants and all kinds
of stuff like that
the data kind of speaks to us and things
emerge from the data all kinds of
pattern or trends without needing any
human annotation and this is a really
big deal because mostly big data is just
really a bunch of noise if we can find
ways to automatically tease these things
out
we as humans will have much less work in
order to be able to understand
what we see
[Music]
you